Вадим Карп'як прошу Вадима Дякую відразу
Сергія шкарлика відрекомендує Міністр
освіти і науки України пане Сергію Вітаю
Доброго дня пане Сергію ми буквально
перед випуском новин спілкувалися із
Анастасією онатій Вона одна з авторок
підручника української мови для п'ятого
класу нової української школи і говорили
про те що через еквестр-бюджету зараз
немає на жаль коштів для друкування
підручників цієї нової української школи
чи є якась можливість хоча б частково
забезпечити підручниками п'ятикласників
Яким це потрібно
Я вам дуже дякую за запитання звісно в
Україні іде війна було декілька
секвестрів бюджету в тому числі На жаль
під цих веслування попали кошти на
забезпечення підручниками але на
сьогодні команда Міністерства разом з
партнерами разом з донорами докладає
максимум зусилля пошуку коштів та інших
джерел щодо фінансування виготовлення
підручників
[музика]
і фонд ю
ність вже є домовленість про друк підруч
для п'ятого класу з математики
української мови загальним накладом
понад 1 млн 300 тисяч примірників інші
підручники будуть доступні в
електронному вигляді на сайті
міністерства та інституту модернізації
змісту освіти окремо хочу подякувати ми
працюємо з цілим переліком видавництв
таких екранів Генеза Orion грамота
літера які погодились частину прибутку
від року книжок відраховувати в фонд
Юнайтед 24 в тому числі і на
у нас трошки під весь зв'язок пане
Сергію Зараз ми спробуємо його
перевстановити тому що уже є зв'язок та
зупинилися обірвалося на тому що частину
своїх прибутків видавництва які друкують
підручники перераховують у фонд Юнайтед
це непогані новини до 1 вересня
залишається вже мало часу пригадує
буквально кілька днів тому ви
повідомляли що приблизно 15% навчальних
закладів серйозно постраждали і не
зможуть почати роботу 1 вересня але я
хотів поцікавитися чи вистачає у нас
вчителів Тому що тільки офіційно 6 млн
українців виїхали за кордон і серед них
Звичайно є і освітяни що у нас з
освітянами зараз
нас освітян яких ми облікували які
виїхали за кордон саме
ніж 22 тисячі на сьогодні в цілому
вистачає нам Враховуючи те що у нас на
жаль 1300 шкіл в окупації але при цьому
дуже сильний рух відбувся між сходом і
заходом
викладачі в тому числі як вимушено
переміщенні особи перебувають на інших
територіях і там теж організовується
освітній процес де сьогодні максимальна
кількість дітей тому нехватки викладачах
на сьогодні немає
школи школи нашої в принципі йдуть
активна робота комісії щодо відновлення
хпроможності
безпекова Навчання вже на сьогодні що 5
липня це було лише 11% шкіл з якісь
стосовно безпекової ситуації готові були
прийняти в очному або змішаному форматі
то на сьогодні вже є цифра 41%, а в
цілому по школах - це 48% готовності до
очного або змішаного навчання А яке буде
домінувати за вашими відчуттями чи може
інформацією
чи заочне навчання в школах
на сьогодні очне навчання заочної форми
навчання ста
ном в нас планують розпочати приблизно
3000 шкіл
в форматі 4000 шкіл і жостко дистанційно
це 5,5 700 шкіл але я сподіваюсь що
все-таки ми зможемо переконати батьків в
тому що школа є територією безпеки ми
про це активно комунікуємо показуємо
розказуємо роз'яснюємо
ну дуже б хотілося щоб так було я чому
цікавлюся цією системою навчання
буквально днями спілкувався з Тарасом
лютим Це український філософ викладач
Університетський він їздить з
гуманітарною місією інших е-е
інтелектуалів на харківщину і вони в
одній із харківських шкіл в одному стіл
Харківщини роздавали книжки дітям і він
розповідав історію яка мене особисто
дуже вразила
третьокласникам е-е він давав книжки і
1/3класниця сказала що Ну навряд чи їй
це зараз дуже потрібно бо вона погано
читає коли з'ясував ну почали
з'ясовувати чому в третьому класі дитина
погано читає виявилася що перший клас
припав на 20-й рік дистанційка через
ковід Тоді дистанційка далі через ковід
тепер через війну і фактично ми маємо
серйозну проблему з цим дистанційним
навчанням яке триває третій рік і воно
позначається на якості
звісно питання дуже зручне навіть після
першого року кавіду ми зробили певну
певну
перемодернізацію скажімо
платформ дистанційних наших платформ де
додали окремі кабінети окремо можливість
робити
дистанційну робити
формат індивідуальної роботи визначення
до індивідуальної траєкторії роботи учня
і вчителя для того щоб вчитель зміг
виявити Отакі саме випадки коли дитина
через ковід те що втратила зв'язок
вчителям або не засвоїла матеріал є
можливість повернутися до засвоєння
окремих тем так і в цілому матеріалу це
вже залежить від майстерності вчителя
е-е більший за все безперечно що це
питання стосунків вчитель-учень і батьки
які би теж можливо вимогливіше повинні
були ставитися до вчителів
але і до дітей в тому числі але просто
прикро е-е що такі випадки є я якось про
це не задумувався поки не зіткнувся з
цим в такій формі добре школи готуються
перше число що у нас стосовно вишів
оскільки
відбулися ну така експериментальна цього
року була система не зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання а
мультипредметний тест Наскільки Ви
задоволені результатами як міністр цього
експерименту
ви знаєте як показала практика
процес вступу ще триває але як показала
практика Це було єдине розумне рішення
проведення аналогу нашого ЗНО Але трошки
іншому зміненому військовому форматі вже
на основну сесію в нас пройшло 180 майже
188 тисяч учасників оцінювання про
проходилось у нас 250 містах
України і в 40 містах Європи
хоча основної сесії в нас майже 20 тисяч
наших вступників склало тест цей за
кордоном на сьогодні вже на 19 серпня В
нас створено 410 000 електронних
кабінетів і понад 716 000 електронних
заяв які подавалися до тих чи інших
університетів на основі повної загальної
середньої освіти 11-го класу в нас
створено майже 466 000 електронних
кабінетів і в
нормально ми очікуємо ще додаткову сесію
до офіціальну сесію яка буде відбуватися
з 10 а а як ви оцінюєте активність
абітурієнтів з тимчасово окупованих
територій
а потім часово окупованим територіїм ще
рано говорити бо в них трошки інший
формат з того і вони всі кодуються ми
будемо мати цю інформацію десь
наприкінці вересня Ми дуже старанно
намагаємося не показувати
всіх з мешканців тимчасово окупованих
територій які набрали сміливості мають
бажання навчатися в закладах освіти тому
що української освіти тому що ну
об'єктивно
це і моральному тиску і фізичному іноді
і для того щоб не наражати їх на на
небезпеку ми публікуємо дані виключно у
форматі і виключно після того як ці діти
вже е-е вступили до закладів української
вищої освіти і перебуває в нас на
безпечній території ну очевидно що в
цьому є сенс резонно е-е але я хотів
тоді уточнити чи передбачає український
законодавство якісь пільги для цих е-е
вступників тому що Очевидно вони не
зможуть скористатися такою
безпосередньою підтримкою сім'ї Як це
можуть робити студенти з контрольованих
територій тобто чи будуть якісь пільги
для них
дуже дуже дякую вам за це запитання адже
президент України ініціював Ще у 20-му
році що вступники з тимчасового
окупованих територій з Криму з Донбасу
на сьогодні в тому числі це і
особливо небезпечні території вступають
за окремою процедурою вони складають
замість nnt індивідуально усно
співбесіду і вступають по окремій котик
Так звана квота два яка дає можливість
навчатися за кошти державного бюджету і
причому в цьому році максимальний обсяг
державного замовлення збільшена з 10 до
40% у переміщених закладах освіти і
квота два збільшена дослідника відсотків
і це буде стосуватися не тільки Крим
Україна Донбас України це стосується
Запорізької області тимчасово окупованої
Миколаївської Сумської Харківської
Чернігівської областей Київської області
там дійшли активні бойові дії там де є
е-е певні проблеми щодо підтримки тих
е-е наших юних мешканців яких там
складні умови обставини або втра
чено п міністра ще одна тема не можу не
запитати недавно Міністерства освіти і
науки підписало меморандум з компанією
Parimatch яка займається букмекерськими
ставками і під цим повідомленням на
офіційній сторінці вашого Міністерства у
Фейсбуці було достатньо багато критичних
відгуків з приводу якраз сфери
діяльності цієї компанії і етичності
такого меморандуму прокоментуєте
є коротко прокоментую але основний
розширений коментар на розмістимо на
інформаційному порталі Міністерства ви
знаєте ми на постійній основі
Міністерства освіти на постійній основі
підписуємо меморанду з багатьма
міжнародними національними фондами
компаніями які націлені на підтримку
освіти здобувачів освіти в тому числі і
е-е з осіб які мають там складні життєві
обставини чому знаєте знову ж таки
диванних експертів зацікавило саме
підписання цього меморандуму з
Міжнародним благодійним фондом який
допомагає саме дітям він нічого немає з
ігоркою другий
наші поспіль фонду Parimatch coundation
э-э
активно співпрацює з міністерством
освіти результатом
минулорічних взаємодії Digital платформа
Active iOS яка там полегшує розвиток
фізичної культури і спорту в закладах
освіти в нас там пройшло більше 70 000
е-е вчителів фізичної культури
прослухали онлайн курси отримали
сертифікати в рамках курсу нова
на культура майже 25 000 вчителів
представників спорту і наукових
експертів взяли участь в освітніх
конкуренціях там у нас ціла ціла низка в
тому числі і соціально-психологічного
адаптації в умовах війни підпост
воєнного синдрому відбувається більш
детально буде все розміщено на
інформаційному порталі Міністерства і
зрозуміло тобто буде окрема комунікація
з цього приводу від імені Міністерства
Дякую за час який ви нам приділили пане
міністр Сергій шкарлет Міністр освіти і
науки України був з нами в ефірі
телевізійного марафону за кілька хвилин
випуск новин із Тетяною висоцькою